hello everyone
welcome back i hope you had fun going
through this uh three notebooks
and just before we leave i'd like to
give you a few references
that are awfully important and useful
for you going forward with the pilots
first of all i already mentioned if
you're interested and want to start
using pilots i strongly recommend to
check out our main documentation
and more importantly we have seen very
briefly how you can create a new
operator and
that has been fun but if you really want
to start
creating new operators please check out
the adding section in our documentation
and
understand all the details that we have
now been able to go through today
and that hopefully will get you started
and able to create
any type and complex type of operator
moreover if you are even more interested
on the
implementation details and want to know
more about the history of pilots
please check out our paper
that we have published a few a year ago
or so
on software x which is freely available
moreover uh we have seen just a very
brief
uh appetizer or what pylops can do
going forward there are two main
locations where you will find
a lot of useful information and useful
examples our tutorial page in the main
documentation
and also here uh this is where i
personally store
most of the notebooks i work on they're
not nice nice and polished as those that
we eventually put in the documentation
but it could be
a good source of inspiration we have
seen that pylops is quite powerful and
useful for
solving problems in different
disciplines and to get the flavor of
different areas of research that are
actually using pilots for
performing cutting edge research we are
trying to store
and uh collect all the different
references to papers that have so far
used by laws
it is quite short right now but there
are quite a few that
are going to come out in the next year
or two
with research that we know and different
people have already
been doing using this library and also
another
sorry very interesting uh direction
where pilots is
going is in the field of astronomy for
the
imaging of strong gravitational lenses
and if you are
not really familiar with this discipline
i really recommend you to check out this
great library where pylopse is now
started to be used to facilitate the
solution of inverse problems
for solving uh actually problems in a
different discipline from the one that
the three of us
uh that we have uh presented pilots they
are familiar with
showing the easy extensibility and also
the flexibility of this library
and finally going forward i like to
mention three different areas where we
have been working on
year and there on and off two libraries
that i will call sibling libraries of
pilots the first
first one is called pylops distributed
the second one is a lot called
gpu distributed is basically a port of
most of the operator
to dusk allowing the uh perform
performing inverse problems in a
distributed system of computers
and so extending the capability of
pilots beyond the single machine
and solving some of the bottom export in
terms of computation and memory
environment
we've also explored for quite a while
the possibility of using pie torch as a
back end compared to numpy and that has
led to
quite a few interesting avenues first of
all
we've been able to create something what
we call the torch operator which is a
overload of a torch module on which you
can
feed any pilots operators so you could
make an impellops operator
actually into an autograd graph
of pytorch so that could be useful when
you want to mix
for example deep neural network with
some physics based
uh processes within the same chain of
operators
and finally this is a very new and very
fresh so far
i've been mostly playing it myself in my
fork but if you are interested to
contribute and you want to see how that
looks like just
please reach out and this is the idea of
actually moving into using coupe i
instead of by
torch when it comes to purely importing
pilots functionalities to gpu
kubai is now a very mature library is
very much
uh one-to-one with numpy so he makes
the change of the code base very limited
compared to having to
kind of rebuild from scratch our library
using pytorch and
it is showing quite a lot of speed up in
several problems so it's uh
something that hopefully will very
quickly make it into the main
codebase if you just want to get in
touch with us
feel free to reach on github and write
an issue whether it's to specific aspect
of the code base or if you are solving a
problem and you're getting stuck
we're also both active on our slack page
but also in the
software underground slack community if
you
are into software and into subsurface
problem is a great place where you can
reach us and also discuss with other
scientists about
different problems of the subsurface
related to software development
an adventure you can also reach out
directly to us on email and linkedin
we are friendly and happy to get more
and more people involved in this project
once again i hope you enjoyed it and
i'll see you in the q a session
you